ben dis moi tu as fais de la télé
apparemment oui oui je considère tout le
monde aurait commis dans la lutte tu
regardes quoi à la télé à part à la
dernière séance
bajeux genre juste la dernière science
aujourd'hui c'est tout arrive
présentement je regarde plus la télé
mais bon mon émission préférée
enfin je sais pas elle va sortir bientôt
du moulin est pas le moment aujourd'hui
la page est celle que tu détestes
démission en règle générale c'est les
fausses variétés ouais ça oui c'est quoi
une fausse vérité que j'en fasse jamais
une fausse variété c'est une émission où
il y à des chanteurs qui apparaissent et
qui servent à rien ouais mais bon
j'avoue que j'en fais normes et moir non
quand je dis qu'ils servent à rien c'est
bon alors chère madame vous êtes
alcoolique
votre mari vous bat bon très bien vous
n'avez pas de mémoire on va vous
demander votre date de naissance alors
vous allez gagner 100 briques et cetera
en attendant voici vivifier
tu as dit en parlant de christine bravo
elle fait une émission pour les deuxième
année de médecine
oui oui c'est pas par jour à tubes ce
savoir est une pêche et d'une formidable
il faut s'adresser zone en dépit des
attaques pas le prendre au sérieux t'a
dit aussi bas je veux pourrait faire le
jeu prenne sur lui et de sa marionnette
ouais je trouve qu'il en fait plus que
non il ne veut pas le prendre au sérieux
parce qu'il a il a dit par exemple un
jour facile toi qui raconte ça il a dit
kenton john était un grand chanteur
aveugle wii noire en plus noir est
aveugle envers l'armée ces formules hâte
de voir cette assurance vie là il a fait
très fort récemment y avait le splendide
e carole bouquet 1
c'est tout un sens et lui a dit lui a
fait des pompes pendant chacun le
bouquet vous avez tourné que les plus
grands metteurs en scène l'univers et
james bond c'est l1 c'est pas grave ça
pose les pieds david lynch qui l'a enfin
il a vu arriver david lynch sur un écran
externe de faux nom tu te souviens
allawi
oui mais ça c'est merveilleux parce que
c'est un aplomb et c'est pour ça que je
dis simplement que bombe
il est plus fort que la marionnette
t'adore les erreurs à la télé d'une
façon générale fait adore les intox et
l'info cette feria ça pour ça c'est bien
ouais c'est bien je laissais pas en même
temps je suppose cependant elle a fait
pas c'est pas le méchant de renom on ya
droit
on ya droit et on fait avec puis ce
pauvre etricks style pauline lafont et
lee 27 et mourir ça c'est
malheureusement ça n'a pas fait revenir
non ça c'était beaucoup plus de peinture
autant bon je plaisante on puisqu'on
parle de rêverie pas vous avoir bon il
se plante pas ce qu'il veut tout faire
bon il sait pour qui et qui ont pu
mélanger les rôles et militaire comme on
dit cherchons les serviettes
non mais
je pense que l'info de la s'inquiétait
beaucoup plus graves infos de l'a5
essayer de faire de l'info à
l'américaine comme on dit de l'info à
scandale et ça ça me dérange plus dis
moi tu es la dent dure par la main non
pas du tout sur base je parle prison de
ton pote jeudi la publication à un
caméléon quoi je veux dire il a changé 2
il a changé de style avec ans ouais ah
si une force complètement barbelivien
par exemple sadi l'a jamais composé une
chanson en mesure maintenant mais il le
dit lui même avant ça va alors c'est pas
moins bon la vie est a dit si la rive
gauche des années 50
et alors il le dit il le leur mais je
vois pas comment il peut dire autre
chose tu as dis je et godard ge et adamo
jeu et dylan et les trois fois les trois
que le courriel c'est pas gentil de à
pardon pourquoi moi qu'est ce que ça
peut [ __ ] en l'air mon émission et qui
m'a bien futur m'asseoir et toi
mais qu'elle soit restée toujours leur
jetaient fromarte et je me suis juré
quatre heures à t'attendre devant les
dents samedi dernier c'est toi ça n'est
pas rentré tu m'as attendu dans l'apport
bah oui c'était attendu bouna pour non
plus et le tarn du tarn à moi je t'ai
dit non en fait l'essai de rentrée ils
foutent à savoir ça vous dérange pas que
le choix des missions au dessus
je suis désolé excuse moi j'ai eu un
empêchement accessoires sait pas à ce
soir j'y suis juré hockey d'or super tu
viens d'aller calmer jusqu'à la fin de
mission
à part ton amitié pour michel charasse
n'ai jamais vraiment affiché d'opinions
politiques travailler avec michel sawas
pas non plus n'ont donc question la
question c'est que jamais pris vraiment
position politiquement non mais j'estime
que j'ai pas en prendre pour ce que je
suis un personnage public
j'ai pas dire à la télévision le thé
pour machin a dit moi puisque on allait
à la conversation de bistrot
l'effondrement du communisme par exemple
eh bien c'est l'intenable isme total moi
j'achète toutes les cartes qui traîne
ouais hystérique dans tout ça staline
n'est pas vraiment quelqu'un klingvall
cieux c'est qu'ils paris qui a encore
des russes staline en france il ya
encore des russes tony barrette je sais
pas si c'est vrai pourtant on met enfin
je comprends pas pourquoi il ya des
russes tu as vu leur garde